julio arias tied for the major league
lead with 12 wins and in the month of
july he's 3-0 with a 2-8-9
7-2 giants on monday 8-6 dodgers last
night their biggest come-from-behind win
this season
to the lead-off man he strikes it now
right back to it
mike gastremski he hit his 15th home run
of the year
last night fastball is hammered
deep right way back there and goodbye
another home run for yaskremsky and the
giants have a one-nothing lead
that's his fourth home run since the
all-star breaks he's had a great road
trip
and he does this one in a two-strike
two-out situation a little fastball
right at the belt
here is logan webb on the bat as the
dodgers come up taylor the big night
last night
three for four couple of home runs
knocked in three
rifled the deep left field chris tanner
weighs no time
tied at one this guy
double and two home runs last night
tonight he doubles the production in his
first event last night it was the
double this time it's the home run are
you kidding me
so hot in a one-on-one game here's tyro
estrada
here's the one-two change-up fouled into
the glove strike three
two gone it's an outstanding change up
starts about
thigh high so the batter comes after it
then it just breaks down just below the
knees with some late movement
two up two down in the second and here's
lamont wade junior
found into the glove strike three
back-to-back case in a one two three
second for ureas
aj pollock 278 13 home runs 34
runs batted in that is all for
aj pollock one away kin street 241
seven home runs and 29 runs batted it
at the knees with that breaking ball
strike three call
on one game third inning back to the top
of the giants order with austin slater
stroke down the line to center field
bellinger coming on
makes a sliding play different nice same
story for cody bellinger in center field
and his mom jennifer applauds like the
rest of dodger stadium
giants won dodgers one each team with a
solo homer in the first chris taylor
at the knees strike three call with a
change up
taylor may be telling him hey don't you
think
if it was a strike i'd be swinging at it
[Laughter]
that's five strikeouts now for webb so
here's max muncie
that change up rough to web
wow he's gotten muncie twice floor is
flying to center in his first at-bat at
250
softly bounce to short for chris taylor
and flores
is out number one one one game fourth
inning pair of solo home runs in this
game
strimski has the one for the giants
a pop-up on the infield
running in to catch it as taylor in the
palm of his glove
boy the shift on that makes for some
unconventional routes to them he runs a
long way but you remember you're talking
about a guy who's playing infield
tonight that plays the outfield very
well
two out darren rough at first we're in
the top half of the fourth
the line drive hitter high average
hitter grounds this one back to
rios rainbow to first to end the fourth
tied at one in l.a last half of the
fourth inning from dodgers stadium
los angeles smith walked his first time
against
logan webb 2-2 on the ground
to third floors had to back up they'll
get the out there solano to first
not in time chance did a pretty good job
making that close
now bellinger he pulls one on the ground
and the giants might turn two here that
throw was low though estrada and it
might not have mattered
two down he's got a chance here to
contribute with his wheels if he can get
the second for aj pollock and get in
scoring position
pilot shoots one down the line that is a
fair ball into the corner
foot racers on for cody bellinger
yaskripski guns it in
descend from evil and a 2-1 lead
on a double from aj palette
aj pollock stays hot this dodger offense
stays hot they were a little late and
how they came to the table
last night down six to one came all the
way back
will smith being the hero but we got to
see something like this with cody
ballinger
and he did it last night and he does it
again midfield hit for estrada brings up
lamont wade jr
he lays a bun down back to julio looks
at second goes to first
tied run to score in position one away
all the wild pitch strata will go to
third
now 3-2 pop-up
not deep enough as good as a strikeout
as muncie makes the catch to gone
julio's 1-2 ground ball to second
muncie's got it and the inning is over
in a 2-1 game here in the fifth chris
taylor comes back to the plate
reaches out and pokes a base hit to
right center field
out of the base hit for chris taylor his
seventh multi-hit game of july two
on with two out for baby
on the ground to first darren ruff's got
it and logan webb gets him on
one pitch for the lead off man austin
slater
on the hands rolled the third zach
mckinstry
a bullet to first here's wilmer flores
200 flores pops it up
pujols
mike ostremski coming up yastremski is
16th home run of the year
in the first maria strikes him out
tripski down on strikes that will end
the inning
five strikeouts for urias right-hander
jay jackson for his fourth
giants appearance got him swinging with
the slider
got him with the fastball two down
slider struck him out swinging what an
inning for jay jackson
he strikes out the side here's julio
rios into the seventh inning having
given up that
first inning home run to mikey schremsky
nothing since
rough leading it off part of the order
solano and estrada to follow
rough tomahawks is one of the ground to
third in mckinstry
one away in the seventh finder on the
board go ahead run at the plate in the
form of tyro estrada
back up the middle muncie taylor
jump throw for two pretty four six
three double play to end the ending back
to the dugout stephen duggar
is now at first as the pinch runner
wilmer flores will come up
that ball is hit high and deep left
field it's on its way
adios
what a moment for wilmer flores and what
a way to get his first
ever hit against kenley jansen
three to two giants lefty lefty gonzalez
against wade
double from ruff walks from solano and
estrada talkman pinch running for ruff
02 big strikeout for victor gonzalez
three to two giants right now three men
on
two men out nowhere to put cause sally
with the bases loaded
he did not get it he did not get that
lone strike
he was so frustrated he collapsed on the
mound there for a moment
the dodgers are losing it victor
gonzalez he looked down to his knee
couldn't believe it
that is a huge run for the giants
ground ball to first albert pujols
feeding gonzalez
that's the inning and dave roberts
between innings was ejected
max muncie was chirping a little bit and
all of a sudden dave
got out of the dugout to protect max but
then decided i'm going to finish the
argument for him and he's going to watch
the bottom of the ninth from his office
judah nobody on pollock pollock knocked
not gonna run rogers
with the pitch and it's tapped out in
front of home plate casale's gonna
pounce on it
his throw to first is there in time and
that's the ball game
the giants with a come-from-behind win
in the ninth innings